is it true sandy you also worked three
jobs at i mean i've always worked three
jobs because i put him in private school
i sent him through college
he played tennis which is not a cheap
sport
but i wanted him to have everything i
didn't have so
we saw your pride you know just as you
beat went by
what does it feel like to have all that
hard work that you put into raising him
pay off i mean the man he's become is
because of you i'm very very proud of
the man he he has become because you
know you see
so many people that don't put in the
effort and i just like to see my reward
because
when i even see him on camera it could
be like a 20-second blip but i'm just
beaming because
he's doing what i was wanting to do i
went to school for journalism
i raised him
he's doing it so i'm i'm living for him
is it true you haven't taken a vacation
in five years
i had a broken ankle
i had to go through four surgeries so
i've been home
for almost four or five years this is my
nurse right here oh
well um
we um we i heard that you were
interested in going to cabo is that true
oh my god that's my favorite place is
that your dream place yes that's my
dream have you ever been yeah i have and
i've always wanted to take him so you
guys have never gone together i've never
been out of the country before
well pack your bags
because we are gonna give you
an all-inclusive trip to the brand-new
[Applause]
spending money because you know i don't
know maybe you need a new suit and like
some chocolates and you know some
sunblock and stuff oh my god
[Applause]
and uh let this be the beginning of a
beautiful friendship please
[Applause]
[Music]
to this show it is literally built for
you thank you so much let's do more
let's play we want to hear all about
cabo
[Music]